Hàn Quốc chính thức chín khai chính xác mến tị thượng nhập cạnh, đối với nhóm số khách tự chú của đại luật.
Lánh xấu mới đều chín quan trọng cho quan hệ sọng phương.
Thật quý định mới, nhóm từ bác người trở lên có thể lưu chú tại hàn Quốc trong vòng mời làm ngày mắc không cần thi thực.
Chó khôn khổ chính trình thị diện kéo sài đến thằng sống năm sau.
Chính xác đưa ra ngày trước thị nghĩ lẽ quốc khán kéo sài từ ngày 1 mồ tiến ngày 1 táng tháng 1 của Trung Quốc.
Thời điểm được dự báo nho cầu dụ lịch nước ngoài khăn cao.
Đồng thời này cũng mang ý nghĩa tên bằng sau khi bắt tình quy định mến tị thượng chú cơm dẫn hàn Quốc từ quý năm ngoài.
Giờ quốc sẽ cho rằng việc khôi phục chính xác mến tị thượng, bốn tình được áp dụng cho dựa đoạn thể bản hội mồ đông,
pương trang, năm ánh hình không trở về bài hành hình không tròm bị tảm.
Hôm chỉ nhằm thúc đại ngành su lịch và têu dùng người điện của Hàn Quốc.
Mà còn phản ánh nỗ lực dạm cân thẳng và cùng có hợp tắc tình tây dõi nước.
Chúng tôi cạnh mối trường để chính trị khu bực nhiều biến đạo.